lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
so we started
i guess no not i guess you have to be
happy about it
i have to be happy about i guess no look
so we got to hear what was it
what 30 minutes ago
and we ate burritos and that's great
gonna give a speech
you know what happens when you eat
burritos you get real sluggish after no
i don't yes you do i don't because
you're human i don't get sluggish after
i eat a [ __ ] brutal we eat somebody
oh so you do what do you do after you
eat a burrito i get you sit down i get
like static
you don't yeah but in your head but then
you sit down nobody eats a burrito i'm
like plays ball is what i'm saying well
that would be a mistake there we go so
you might
argue that eating a burrito makes you
lethargic yes got out of that one so
what happens is you you eat a burrito
and then you start slowing down it's
just what happens the blood the drug the
blood draws to your tummy and helps you
digest you know why i think that happens
to you because you don't eat
you wait too long to eat and so when you
wait too long to eat and then you eat a
lot your your body crashes yes
no that's not necessarily true sometimes
i eat as a matter of fact i ate about
two hours ago so i didn't wait too long
yeah i remember eight square i told you
a squirrel you're eating too much okay
well look i'm eating fine this isn't
what this is about but what i'm saying
is you eat a burrito and then you don't
play ball right that's so right so we
need to be bald we're not playing ball
no i know but we need to bring the ball
player energy to this podcast to
separate it from the other [ __ ]
sounds like you're doing good though so
i'm holding my weight because i know i'm
on the [ __ ] upswing of the burrito
thing oh you're holding your weight all
right i had [ __ ] two meals in two
hours all right
so that's good right oh so mad
so
mad cause because you gotta eat the
burrito and then you gotta go go go go
go go go go go go but what you were
doing is like well let's leave the air
on let's leave the place cool you went
to the bathroom two times because you
were not using the bathroom oops right
you were just in there like toodling and
[ __ ] it was hot in here
insecure nelly it was it was hot in here
okay it was hot in
why is it so insecure to swallow in
between words an audible swallow because
you're not [ __ ] confident in what
you're saying it's not necessarily true
which is why i ask the question yes
so that's a that's a yes for me no and
it's why i ask the question because it's
implied in the question that isn't
necessarily an insecure thing to do to
swallow if you are
um
if you are saying something very
definitive you don't swallow because you
have the next word to say immediately
if you're talking and you're not really
i'm sure what you're
gonna say you end up swallowing and
people like that guy's a [ __ ] i'm not
doing anything he said that's why all
the greats in history never [ __ ]
swallowed in between words martin luther
king jr
i know i shouldn't say
hitler's the other guy next guy who came
to mind i know that's bad but like i'm
just saying guys
that have a [ __ ] terrible i know but
but they had a lot of people behind them
is all i'm saying
because they didn't swallow the second
anyone's like uh this is why [ __ ] joe
biden loses people you're saying and i'm
not politically influenced you're not
saying whether they're good or bad no
not good or bad i'm saying influence all
right strength cult leadership
projecting strength yeah that's why all
the preachers talk like this
so you think the reason they project
strength is because they don't swallow
100 and that's literally the only reason
nope
well if you would like to follow me into
the road
i would like to see that though well so
would i but you wouldn't like to follow
that guy no well i wouldn't follow
any preacher or cult leader which is
what you seem to be doing right there
but what i'm saying is so we need to
have the upswing of the burrito right
and if we have the upswing of the
burrito then we start before we let the
lethargic [ __ ] before the blood all gets
drawn to the tummy
so now we're activated and we're here
and we're we're in the ballplayer energy
bringing it to the podcast i'm feeling
honestly a little bit sluggish right now
that's why because we [ __ ] started
too late it could be
so f so that's what i'm saying and you
were just like dilly dallying and when
we had the [ __ ] upswing and now i've
got to carry the upswing but i'm doing
it mentally not physically because we're
starting too late because i know about
the whole [ __ ] upswing it was [ __ ]
hot
[Laughter]
so we wanted it to [ __ ] cool down
because the ac is loudest [ __ ] [ __ ]
in here i understand but what we have to
do is make sure
it's it's like the lesser of two evils
right and it's better to have a better
podcast and be sweating under the pitch
than it is to i see right wrong but i
still do something wrong i need to be
hot we need because what do you sweat
let me play ball
yes
see you've developed this thing now
where you clap for yourself thank you
and i don't like that at all i know i
developed it because that's what i do
when i because there's no audience here
you know i do a lot of study stand up
right i do know by the way speaking of
stand up phoenix arizona april 30th i
will be there go to chrysalia.com to get
tickets i added a second show and all
the [ __ ] good seats are full but go
in and get that [ __ ] it's going to be
there april 30th on saturday
so i'll see you guys there
and uh yeah so that's it no that's rude
that's very rude but you you won't be
there you won't be sluggish as [ __ ] no
so you asked one thing before the
podcast which would have been a great
thing to ask during the podcast but we
started too late but we can go back what
did i ask you said why do i wear
sunglasses why do you wear sunglasses
sometimes i think i'm ugly
well you're not always right but i can't
argue with you on that sometimes i think
i'm ugly and i started with the
sunglasses on because sometimes my eyes
look bad
but he's going to admit it dude he's
going to admit it because what because
people like what's real what percent of
the time do you think that you look ugly
enough
okay well i mean i think well
okay that's a great question actually
thank you um i have my angles
right see you said two answers neither
of which were actual answers to my
question you said enough and then you
said i have my angles the question was
what percent of the time do you think
you're ugly you tell me dude i want the
percent
okay well
a hundred percent though um no i i um i
look i i don't ugly as a stretch but i
look bird-like sometimes i look gaunt i
look [ __ ] a new color
translucent off death yeah you look
really white do you never outside dude i
was outside earlier and it's like
it didn't even take dude i was outside
for a while doing push-ups you know me
right yeah i guess i was doing push-ups
and sit-ups and doing planks you know me
right outside yeah yeah and so i was
outside and i was [ __ ] doing all that
stuff i was even doing jumps and dips
out of the pool you know me right i do
know you stopped asking me if i know
you're right so i was bulked up
you know what's interesting about me but
the [ __ ]
the raise bounced off me power
can
i can be uh remember the guy
uh i can be outside for five minutes and
i get a 10. well
you know yeah okay that's fine that's
fair
that's good i'm not trying to rub it in
or anything but i know but you always
have had that [ __ ] dark [ __ ] like
that italian that [ __ ] you you know
what i mean yeah that's [ __ ] yeah i
mean i love it about about myself yeah i
know i i don't like my color but it's
fine dude but also on the king of this
thing in the wing they [ __ ] have that
bright light on me and [ __ ] so i look
even worse i think they're [ __ ]
jealous dude
do you think it's like a frame job no
because they [ __ ] it was like that
were
already from whatever so you talked
yourself out of it i know yeah it was a
quick one so um all right so so we you
want to just jump right into it dude
this is lifeline when i say that it's
been like 10 minutes you can't say i
want to jump right so you guys want to
when it's already been like a long time
let's jump right in okay let's jump
right in but but um
let's joe biden we could do that all
right joe biden jump right in let's joe
bite in
the first one definitely
shut the [ __ ] up wow what's going on
there's no person there
there's bloody over here my roommate
has a big problem where he just drinks
and just gets blacked out every single
day it seems like you're on your way
into a week
so
so many chairs i just was making this
video
to see if you guys have any advice on
how i should handle it because i'm going
to be living with this idiot for the
next two years
oh
oh my that was dude incredible sign off
oh my god signed on and off with that
that the the last one though was wild so
violent you know what if you did it 25
times it was good break his computer
screen you know yeah yeah first of all
too many chairs okay so many chairs in
the back there yeah second of all was so
weird to hear the guy but not see the
guy that was like i would have said like
he's hearing voices but we heard it
right we heard it uh guy is absolutely
high as [ __ ] while he's doing it
i mean his eyes were just like this
she's trying to something i don't know
if he was high um yeah he was on he was
on something yeah and so uh he's asking
how to deal with his roommate who's
always blacked out no he's just
were you listening or i did i tried
listening he said his roommate's always
sliding down he's about to get so drunk
on weekends that he blacks out and he
said it's turning into a weekday thing
yeah yeah so that is what i said no it's
not i said you how to deal with this
room when he blacks out
okay yes got out of that one dude
um no so i think that honestly this dude
uh needs to just for real either get a
um
you know if he if he's not strong enough
to lift him [ __ ] power up with your
squats do dead lifts you know some
[ __ ] farmer's carries and whenever
the guy passes out just [ __ ] pick
them up and put them in the closet
put them in the closet or if you don't
want to do that if you're lazy piece of
[ __ ] which
you are right because look at your eyes
are half masked okay which yar then just
get a [ __ ] big blanket get a big
[ __ ] weighted blanket and put it over
him wherever he [ __ ] blacks out and
falls down and when he wakes up he'll be
sweaty as [ __ ] and when he gets up he'll
be pushing that weighted blanket off him
and he'll be like oh man what the [ __ ]
and i and then you say and you say well
you're [ __ ] sweaty and you'd be like
yeah and then you say well that's what
you get you're sweaty because you
[ __ ] blacked out and i put a weighted
blanket on you it's like little [ __ ] you
got to do to ruin their lives it's not
big things this is the first go-to thing
that you think this guy should do you
think the first thing he should do
are those two things that you said i
mean after talk to him but yeah so so
okay
so then because i think that's because i
think that he probably already did and
also that kind of considered that's
considered talking to him the guy was in
the room and he was making a video for
us we didn't see him though i'm a little
suspicious because we didn't see him we
heard it we did hear it but he looks
behind him and there's nobody there yeah
but it was he was just below him on the
couch i feel like he was sitting on top
he was just hiding behind his ass like
this right um yeah i think
well first of all
he specifically said two years of this
so it's been two years two years
it's gonna be two years he's locked into
some kind of lease oh wow okay
or maybe it's college i don't i don't
know get away to block it the the
you gotta
for your own sake i mean yes it's
obviously for his well-being and his
health but for your own sake you gotta
just [ __ ] talk to him say can we at
least try pulling back on the drinking
because the truth is nobody wants to
[ __ ] black out
it's worse than a hangover dude there's
nothing i don't drink anymore but when i
used to
i never really had blackouts but i did
like once or twice and it is [ __ ]
truly scary you lose time you wake up
and you don't remember what the [ __ ]
happened whoa and people will tell you
you did this you did that you did that
and you're just like i
have to believe you yeah because all of
you are saying this but i have no
recollection of that yeah and it sounds
memorable it's always like a [ __ ]
dumb thing wow it's not like you have so
much fun with this
it's it's it's that's actually a dark
first thought no no it's not dark it's
fun you put a [ __ ] you he falls
asleep blacks out yeah and then you get
i mean how long do they people back out
for sometimes hours right well no i
think you have a misunderstanding of
what blackout means yeah you you you
drink so much
and then you
pass out and then you wake up the next
morning and
it's like you've blacked out your memory
there's no memory of it great right
right okay so when you're chilling
you're not passed out you're blacked out
right you're in the future you will yeah
you will have forgotten right sure yeah
okay so then you just convince the drunk
person who's blacked out that don't know
their blackout to do a bunch of crazy
[ __ ] like let's go to the costume store
you get [ __ ] samurai outfits okay you
get maybe cat ears or some [ __ ] okay and
then you have a great time at home you
set up decorations like you bring
foliage inside and then he falls asleep
and you wait in your samurai outfit and
then when he wakes up and he goes what
the [ __ ] happened you say i don't know
man and then you try to figure it out
with him like it's a fun little [ __ ]
dinner party
that would be fun as [ __ ] cause here's
the thing if a guy's gonna be having
that much fun and i'm gonna have to deal
with it on the raw end of it you better
believe i'm gonna be making the best of
it right so i'm the roommate it's like
this guy always blacks out it sucks i'm
gonna be making the best of it i'm gonna
turn lemon into lemonade and that's
honestly what he should do okay the to
me that doesn't sound that fun the
costume sort of thing but i get as a
person who blacked out get what you're
saying you don't have to do the samurai
thing you can do bunches right exactly
right but i think pick what based on
what i'm getting is that this guy's not
gonna this guy himself probably likes to
party considering the state of his eyes
i'm sure his hair so i think maybe just
say look
i'm here to help you maybe find a sweet
spot of getting
wasted and having fun but checking like
stopping before you pass the threshold
of blacking out like almost make it a
game like let's test where the line of
blacking out is
i don't think so that's not fun though
that is not supposed to be fun got a
[ __ ] dream problem right but you're
trying to make it fun for the guy like
make it a challenge but he's not four
it's like calvin when i told calvin oh
calvin we got to clean up who can do it
the fastest it is like oh i tricked him
it's an adult version but not drunk he's
gonna remember this okay well it's not a
literal one-to-one samurai outfits and a
way to blanket okay those years we
figured it out those are the two
different pieces of advice i suggest you
try mine
yeah if you don't want to have any fun
and be boring about it so three
countries so let's see what's next
hey matt and chris huge fan of both of
your podcasts max headroom i just wanted
to come on here a little anonymously to
ask for some advice cool so i know that
you guys are super close siblings i am
also pretty close to my siblings my
sister is 25 i'm 28 my brother's 35. so
our thing is that we all currently are
living at my parents house my sister
just graduated college um i'm actually
moving out june 1st
and my brother has been here for a while
so my issue is with him he is 35 he
has no aspirations of moving out of the
house and he doesn't have a full-time
job
even though he has two degrees
um
my issue is that the last couple months
i've really seen who he is as a person
and i am not a fan
he is disrespectful to my parents even
though he's living under their roof he's
incredibly cheap like he'll venmo
request me for three dollars but if i
put everyone's meal on my card he won't
pay me back because he assumes that
since i have a full-time job i'm loaded
oh my god
and just little things like if my sister
and i go out and he wasn't invited he'll
straight up ask me well why didn't you
invite me and i'll say oh well you would
you wouldn't even have wanted to do it
and he says
oh i would have at least liked to be
invited so that i could say no thank you
like i think it's the most respectful
thing to not invite somebody to
something that they don't want to do am
i right yeah
yeah but anyways
struggling with how to move forward with
this relationship
um because it's just really tense in the
household do i have a conversation
where
both of us are going to be uncomfortable
i know for a fact he's going to play
victim take everything personally yeah
and then potentially kind of ruin
our relationship because i do love him i
just can't stand him and if we were
friends we would not be friends right
or
do i just ignore it because there's a
foreseeable end to
us
living together
and just deal with it or you know
any other solutions because it's just
super tense super stressful on me and at
the same time i think he's kind of tone
deaf to the whole situation because he
just like i said plays victim and
doesn't see how he could do any wrong
ever
um thank you for any and all advice
congratulations on this amazing new
podcast can't wait to see
uh where it goes all right love you guys
so much thank you thanks love you too so
long but so long for what is this soft
white underbelly okay go ahead what's
software underbelly oh it's that [ __ ]
where they just talk for an hour and a
half um
so first and foremost
and there's a lot to get into there but
the first thing that jumps out at me
what no [ __ ] it was an hour and a half
is
if the two options that as far as you
see them are have a conversation with
them and it'll be uncomfortable or don't
and like sort of like let it go and see
how it happens if you do option two
that [ __ ] is gonna fester in a way that
you have no idea what the future will
bring like
what happens when we sit on [ __ ] like
that yup when we repress [ __ ] like that
is that it comes out in ways that you a
don't foresee but be in ways that you
really don't want to behave and i think
that even though option one is so uh
unappealing and gonna be so
uncomfortable yeah you [ __ ]
have to do that because repressing it
and sitting on it this is gonna make
[ __ ] worse in ways that will surprise
you in ways that are actually worse than
even just living with them as it is also
spin moves help that you know that okay
i want to talk to you about something
that's considered an intervention i
don't want the eye stop
giving
spin move as your first piece of advice
no it's not but it can help if you got
to [ __ ] tell something some somebody
something very serious about something
just go in do a spin start with you like
cross though it helps if you're barry
sanders is coach no okay and that's it
no
start with your legs cross those what
i'm saying and with your back to the
person and then turn around and when you
[ __ ] your legs even out and you spin
around go not painting the three bucks
and that [ __ ] helps dude that can
help and and furthermore because you're
already in a role but anyway
here's what i think okay first of all
she's right it's respectful for her not
to ask that you're dealing with two
different people that want two different
things and have two different ideas
about
uh
who each other even are right so like
she she thinks it's respectful to not
ask him do a thing that he wouldn't go
like i wouldn't invite you to go to the
[ __ ] opera right i would like to go
to the opera you know what i'm saying
though and obviously i didn't say that
then no but that was a bad example okay
but you know what i had so i wouldn't be
the whole world's gonna [ __ ] see this
i don't want the whole world thinking i
don't want to go to the [ __ ] opera so
i do and when i said opera i was like
this [ __ ] weirdo's gonna want to go
to them you shouldn't have said it then
know me better no but i know but you'd
want to go to the italian opera yeah
you don't know what they're saying no i
don't need to no dude they have the
[ __ ] subtitles anyway okay so um
so they have subtitles in an opera it's
live
they already got a fat [ __ ] guy come
out with tails on just with the cards of
what people there's a big screen i
[ __ ] your wife like on top
not in the opera you know there's a big
screen on top
and as you sing it's like karaoke it's
like it becomes goes from white to blue
that's [ __ ] no it's not i'm saying
it sucks that that's like that
maybe yeah it does dude you need a fat
[ __ ] italian greasy fuck-up just
walking by being like i stole your
tomatoes that's what they're singing
about wow the worst song ever the worst
song ever now you're [ __ ] you know
you'd want to go see an opera about an
italian guy's stealing tomatoes yeah i
mean yeah you would dude yeah okay so
what was the [ __ ] thing about you
okay so so um i would hey matt let's go
work out i would never invite you to go
work out correct that's related
right
and you want to [ __ ] watch the opera
okay it's because it involves sitting
down anyway i don't want to watch the up
i want to go to the okay so
so anyway it is respectful to nothing
like one time remember you and chris
were on my text chain with you guys
talking about game night and i was like
what the [ __ ] are you guys talking about
and then you guys said we have a game
night and i said how long has it been
going on and you said two years and i
didn't know about it for two years and
you never invited me and that was when i
realized that you guys were my closest
friends deeper no no oh oh that's great
yeah right right because you guys know i
wouldn't come to a [ __ ] shitty
[ __ ] game night you would never yeah
right so i thank you for that what did i
do i said thanks guys i really
appreciate you know who i am because one
time i sat at a coffee shop every single
day and there was a guy who was there
who was a stunt man he looked like a
ferret and he was there every single day
and we were talking every day we knew
each other this was like for a year and
then one time he handed me a book and
said you should really check this out
and it was a book on buddhism you don't
know me
dude you don't know me at all was he
like evangelist like no he wasn't even a
religious guy he was like you know i'm
just a stunt man but you should check
this book out you haven't been listening
to me at all you don't know me that's
disrespectful right so that's what
you're saying so that's good okay but
here's the deal though it's never going
to change unless you bring it up it just
won't it won't change unless you bring
it up but here's the deal you bring it
up 99 of the time it's just gonna lead
to a rift anyway it's gonna lead to a
rift anyway the guy has two degrees but
it's really hard and the the pandemic
and everything with how tight money is
and the coronavirus it [ __ ] everybody
up dude dude it'll never not everybody
the smartest people book smartest people
have the most tactless
yeah
disrespectful clueless [ __ ] out
in the world yeah
it's common it's [ __ ] common yeah and
and and uh and i have both book smarts
and real smarts and you don't you
absolutely don't uh and so
so the point is it [ __ ] people up i
mean we
we've all we all have good friends that
all of a sudden now just because a
[ __ ] the of the coronavirus they
think joe biden is a hologram like
literally that you could see the
trajectory it was like oh [ __ ] okay
well oh mass or this or that oh yeah
then joe biden's a hologram like it
takes [ __ ] eight or nine months yeah
but you go from wear this mask to joe
biden is a hologram
in [ __ ] nine months you can do that
dude yeah right it happened it did
happen to a bunch of people a bunch of
people that we all know people we know
oh yeah so and and that's fine if you
want to believe that but
it's but you know
the pandemic and the uh and everything
has affected people in such weird ways
that maybe it's just best to [ __ ]
move out yourself do you know what i'm
talking about sure because that's an
option then i would actually recommend
that because
you don't want to live with this
[ __ ]
this guy sounds problematic on a number
of levels yeah you should rather not
deal with that being said if if the only
options are the two options she laid out
you gotta talk yeah you gotta [ __ ]
talk to me i have a third option try and
move out yourself but that's my third
option no spin move
you don't need to spin move you're not
gonna see him you could do spin move on
moving day you could do a spin move out
of the house yeah yeah okay well good
fixing the world one [ __ ] problem at
a time but talk to him yeah talk to him
yeah okay next one
hi chris and matt so i'm 23 years old
and i'm as i'm growing i'm trying to
identify ways in which
i can be less of a
sucky person in general
so
one thing one flaw that i've been able
to identify uh within myself is that
oftentimes you know i just
disagree with people just for the sake
of being different
and i i hate that because
i know that it does make sense and
that is not how it should be i mean
being neutral is much better than just
disagreeing for the sake of this
succeeding because that's really not
helping anyone right so
and i feel that you guys do a great job
with that because through your podcast
or comedy or whatever form that is you
guys do a great job of being
not disagreeing just for the sake of
discipline right so uh how would you
suggest uh that you know i go about
stepping out of this space that i'm in
and just um
being
someone who is not uh you know a sucky
person
okay first of all
[Applause]
we need more people like that in the
world that is a [ __ ] that guy's 23
and realizing a major [ __ ] flaw and
wanting to change it that is a bravo to
this guy i can't wait to talk
well no go ahead no you're talking i
cannot
wait to talk but go ahead i think you
can wait to talk and you're and you're
buying time okay the floor is [ __ ]
yours go ahead
go no no i want you to go okay well
because i got the camper baby boy jesus
[ __ ] christ um oh dude what i'm gonna
say is so [ __ ] unreal go ahead he's
he's saying he doesn't want to be a
contrarian for the sake of it even
though he is
i mean
the advice is to just [ __ ] follow
through on what you've already realized
about yourself you've done such a good
job
people are so
[ __ ] unaware of themselves first of
all second of all especially when it
comes to their own flaws
and dude
you've inspired me whatever i don't
think he said his name but i'm very
pleased to see there's a 23 year old man
in the world being like
i suck
and i want to [ __ ]
change this way that i suck
uh as far as how
just keep recognizing and realizing okay
[ __ ] go you're pissing me off no no
no no i
jesus dude no i hear you i don't mean to
piss i don't mean to piss you off well
it's too late okay but here's the thing
dude first of all wearing the most video
game shirt in the world dude it had a
camera a palm tree and a [ __ ] panda
on it for no reason you can get that
after you get 40 coins but dude
okay
you
disagree with people for no reason so
somebody will say something and then you
will just disagree with them for no
reason you're identifying that as shitty
okay
people come up and they say i like
apples and you may like apples but you
go you know what though apples aren't
that good if they're not ripe and this
and that plus which apples do you like
and also have you ever tried an orange
now that's shitty you're realizing it
but what you don't realize you're doing
is saying something and then checking
yourself and being contrary to yourself
tyler durden dude this is fight club
you're doing what you're doing out of
the people that yourself just keeping it
fair get a grip dude you're living in a
[ __ ] you're living in your own world
stop what you're doing to yourself first
and then do it to other people
he gets the psyche oh my god
dude it's unbelievable the guy's doing
it to himself dude but
yeah okay yeah a way in a way yeah
don't show me the back of your head it's
so [ __ ] disrespectful
tyler durden
took a whole
a
minute
[ __ ] minute and got so sweaty you
know i'm so sweet yeah for sure for sure
uh
i still think bravo to this guy he might
be like overthinking it and i get that i
can [ __ ] you know what i fully
identify with this [ __ ] i have
experienced all the things that he's
saying what i haven't experienced is
that the entire time he couldn't think
of the [ __ ] word which is contrarian
he kept just saying sucky person
that's the 23andme yeah yeah for real
but but i gotta say still
bravissimo to this [ __ ] because
it's true honestly also those people do
suck now here's the thing though and i
feel strongly about this because i've
been told that i've been called a
contrarian in my life just because you
have strong opinions about [ __ ] that
don't align with the person you're
talking to doesn't make you a contrarian
so that's number one you might you can
naturally
be disagreeing with a lot of people but
just because you're
opinionated doesn't mean that you're a
contrarian or as you would say sucky
person that being said if you actually
are
saying things you don't think just to
disagree with people you're right in
that that is one of the most annoying
[ __ ] things that people do that's
horrible so just
it's good
don't overkill it with an over awareness
you're on the right track already it
sounds like you'll [ __ ] get there
you're still really young i think you're
doing it right already
he recognized it that's fine i mean
you're basically at the point where you
shot yourself in the head and you
realize you're two people yeah tyler
durden at least he recognized he's tired
of durden yeah dude hear that song at
the end [ __ ] stop yeah
building's [ __ ] blowing up
you know that song dude good yeah it's
good good i love that song actually yeah
what is it pi uh it's the pyroxes isn't
it pixels yeah the pixels yeah
the [ __ ] pixels uh yeah i do a good
rendition of it though the pixels yeah
yeah they're good at it yeah all right
well that's good you're tyler durden um
he did good that guy okay
chris and matt is the written one chris
and matt i had been seeing this guy for
the past year we got along great he
checked off all the boxes and we met
each other's families all was going well
or so i thought up until recently when
he told me he'd quote like to put things
on pause for a while so he could quote
think about some things and figure
things out end quote we haven't spoken
since then and i've given him his space
but i've never been told that before so
i'm unsure how to look at this situation
should i see this as a breakup and move
on chris you want to take this one first
yeah
you broke up yeah it sucks here's the
thing that sucks can you put it back up
the guy's a [ __ ] though the guy is a
[ __ ]
little wussy man worthy boy who you
don't want to be with anyway because you
can't even just say
i don't think this is working out
uh
we need to think about some things and
figure things out
this is [ __ ] because it sounds like
he's already done that and not letting
you in on the fact that he has done that
yeah he's like disallowing you from
being where he's at
he's not up front he's a [ __ ]
this is this is a week the week week
week thing to do
and this is not a guy you want to be
with yeah no he's being a [ __ ] about it
he wants to make sure that he can get
over you before
you can get over him because when he's
over you then you start dating other
people and you're out of that zone for
of taking space and he won't feel bad
about you [ __ ] doing the horizontal
mambo with some other guy right yeah
maybe that or he's just afraid to tell
you what he actually [ __ ] thinks and
that is almost as annoying as when he
opened the [ __ ] candidates no dude
[ __ ] open the [ __ ] thing
right when i was driving the point yeah
that was a bad time to do it
i get mad at him a lot for that about
time to do it but dude so the point is
yeah the guy is either a [ __ ]
or
a [ __ ] right and in one way he's either
a [ __ ] of not telling you because he's
afraid of what you'll think or
he doesn't want you to date other guys
while he goes out and [ __ ] doinks
other chicks and can do what he wants
and play the field and then maybe get
someone else to help him mend his broken
heart
while you're sitting at home [ __ ]
because you're this is what this happens
though this happens you know what might
be good though just go do the [ __ ]
yeah
i think he did break up with you but i
think you should call him out on it in a
way that's like
why can't you just say no it's over yeah
dude no yeah it's over anyway she might
as well point out how and help him out
in the future dude he shouldn't be doing
this to people if you're gonna break up
with somebody [ __ ] break up with him
yeah but you just [ __ ] do you do what
you do anyway and you don't even [ __ ]
deal with him anymore he's done he's
done for you
yeah i mean sure you're going to do sure
go [ __ ] for real sucks and dicks and
late late lay flat i will say though i'm
sorry that
it does this sucks yeah it does suck but
it's but
it's also a good thing because he's
helping you figure out that you don't
want to be and so are we we're helping
you move on you got to move on and
[ __ ] lay flat for some dudes he did
you a favor yep that sounds like boring
sex though what if she wants to get up
and get crazy boring sex is the best sex
well not the word boring is in boring
sex how could it be good if it's boring
okay because you can literally do what
you want in your mind if it's boring you
can't if all these [ __ ] bells and
whistles are going like it's what people
say like tie me up how about like with
me how about instead of doing what you
want in your mind you do what you want
period are books better than the movies
are books better a lot of people say
books are better than the movies depends
on the book in the movie
right but i'm saying
well okay but if the book was first the
book is better most not always
the godfather is a great example of that
being wrong okay
that's
name another
uh the book
it was a good book they wrote that after
the movie though um all right so
i'm saying like
i like to when i like to do
when i like to have sex
no music
okay right because i like to do the i
like to feel what's in my head much like
driving i drive to no music okay
right i want to feel what i feel okay 4
30 in the daytime doing the horizontal
mambo with you know
my fiancee we have a good time no
extra [ __ ] you know what i mean lingerie
is for the birds it's just me it's just
yeah so anyway uh anyway that guy
[ __ ] sucks he did you a favor even
though he didn't mean to so he doesn't
get credit for that but take it and run
with it [ __ ] that guy date somebody who
when he breaks up with you let's hope he
doesn't but when he does he has the
[ __ ]
courage to just be like you know what i
don't think this is working out yeah
it's so it's not even that [ __ ] hard
guy [ __ ] that guy it's hard i guess it
is but then it's over
yeah but it's better than drawing it out
like this then you got to see your
[ __ ] doink and other dudes and [ __ ]
pictures of like stor you know some
somebody's on her story and it's like a
guy's arm and you're like who's that why
don't you just not follow her because
he's who he is he's gonna
well [ __ ] him we're not worried about
him we're worried about her poor dude
i'm just saying we're worried about her
all right okay
hey guys everybody knows it's okay to
have a different colorways in shoes but
is it okay to have different colorways
in clothes because in norway it's always
cold so don't mind drugs so i got this
gray one
i got a black one and just in case i got
a brand new of the black one wow um
so different colorways and clothes is it
okay or do you look like you always
wearing the same clothes all the time
thank you guys
wow that guy's [ __ ] cute as [ __ ]
clear up the clear up what he was asking
because
oh yeah yeah okay so uh colorways is
like different colors of different uh
of the same [ __ ] like if i have these
shoes i have the gold colorway and also
a different colorway why is it why are
you saying colorway it's stupid as [ __ ]
it should just be different color it's
the term when it comes to like clothing
and [ __ ] it's like so it's not a brand
no okay so i have this in the red
colorway and also the green colorway and
also the yellow colorway it's from abc
it's from advisory board crystal oh i'm
not liking this i don't like it either
but when i learned it i i was annoying
and then i and then it kind of was like
okay so this is what you got to do
because it's the one thing where it's
like were you gonna not say it i got the
different colors of this then you just
sound like a [ __ ] idiot or a
contrarian or a sucky person a sucky
person right and so it's like you just
gotta [ __ ] if you can't beat them
join them it's one of those things so
anyway what he's saying is a lot of
people have different colored shoes you
know me i come in with the [ __ ]
yellow shits and then the next day i'll
come in with the same [ __ ] but the red
shirts right yeah yeah yeah and so
that's a colorway so what what he's
asking is is okay what first of all why
is everybody in this [ __ ] episode
dressing like a goddamn video game
but he's got the gray
shirt with the camouflage and then he's
got the same shirt in black with the
camouflage is that okay to do with
everything besides shoes is what he's
asking no okay right yeah and of course
the whole thing is do what you want to
do but he's going to get made fun of
people are going to be like didn't you
wear that yesterday you're going to have
to be like no i actually wear the
[ __ ] the other one's more gray and
that's annoying but i think also
the whole point is it doesn't matter
because you're in norway you know what i
mean if you're in norway you can kind of
wear whatever you want you ever seen a
norwegian out on the streets dude you
ever meet a norwegian they don't have
[ __ ] signs i am from norway exactly
but you can tell who they are by the way
they dress they'll wear like a [ __ ]
bright orange shirt that's true but not
like a cool one like a [ __ ] like
where did you get this shirt from like
is it in one of those circular racks in
rite aid like they wear those type shits
and like really high short shorts and
[ __ ] backpacks that are like high up
and you're like that guy's [ __ ]
obviously norwegian yeah and he's saying
that this is the kind of guy that not
only would have the bright orange shirt
the bright red one the bright purple one
the bright [ __ ] green one and
different high color backpacks and
honestly i think it's fine dude but just
know you're gonna have conversations
about it especially if you're in america
and also you're dressing like a video
game
i think that the answer is absolutely
you can have the same shirt
in
all every single [ __ ] color and you
can only wear that if that's what you
want to do i think anybody that thinks
that that's not
a good thing is that that person is so
[ __ ] annoying yeah it's like where
where
where are they even in the same color
like ernest ernest goes to jail and just
goes to camp [ __ ] yeah remember he
would go through his clothes
ronald mcdonald too yeah yeah yeah mr
rogers would wear the same thing mostly
what are you really i don't know oh you
made that up uh yeah i kind of did i
just made that up mr rogers would wear a
lot of stuff that was just like an
argyle sweater or something or like a
[ __ ] blue v neck um and basically
that doesn't count you're the norwegian
mr rogers
uh he's norwegian earnest straight up if
you want to be norwegian artist do it
but yeah dude if they're different
colors of course yes hey yvonne
hey vaughn we scout stupid today yeah
[Laughter]
all right next hey we're at the beach
today yeah ernest at the beach huh
give me my high backpack sexiest man
alive so sexy
we gotta start it over
we gotta start over he's too sexy we've
gotta turn around wow worst camera
[ __ ] up
all right hey uh chrissy and uh matt
so i have a question so my friend uh
lids or my girlfriend friend girl
there she does not like uh the long hair
i asked it for my hair long is better
long down she doesn't know herself
and she said i should cut it she doesn't
know herself i like it down i like it up
whatever but it's been running over
since covid what do you guys think and
if i should
either cut it is it bad for like
relationships or what you're just taking
on a long hair in general
i mean i'm a tall five seven you know
all five seven so it makes me i don't
know what you think about that or what
did they put all the variables together
and you tell me
i mean dude five a seven dude
five seven you can't beat a tall or
short five seven you can only be a five
seven a short five seven there's only a
short five seven oh so the bottom of his
hair is [ __ ] three 3-5
that's him dude
remember that [ __ ] of course rico suave
dude but you're [ __ ] shorter
that's how he talks his hair literally
drags on the ground dude
he's [ __ ] orco no no no what was the
[ __ ] cousin it from uh what's it
called adam's family dude adam's family
dude hey man oh my god first of all this
is a travesty okay
i thought you were six foot two
hey guy grow okay you're six foot you're
not six foot two you're five foot seven
i would say if you were six foot two she
doesn't know herself and here's the deal
she likes the contrarian aka
what sucky person in you because you're
the guy who does what she doesn't want
which is grow your hair long when she
says she likes it not long
because that's what's sexy but all bets
are off the table because of what
if i've seven okay
every guy who's five seven should have
short hair period it's like wearing a
[ __ ] lawn crunch coat you don't do
that you're five seconds you look
shorter you gotta cut your hair
oh i see okay well first of all i
disagree with oh just top to bottom
everything you're saying no way dude but
i agree that he should cut it and here's
why
you
he said that's his girlfriend right he
said friend girl he did not say
girlfriend he said friend girl which
made me think that maybe they're just
[ __ ] doinking okay but she's a cutie
though they're both cuties i think that
oh he's [ __ ] i didn't see her really
but he's super sexy he's five seven but
yeah well okay anyway that's very bad he
should cut his hair because his partner
likes it better when his hair's short
it's as simple as that
yeah
it's as simple as that you're gonna hurt
your neck no you do what you want and
the partner likes you you're you're
breaking down the different things of
him the partner likes him he is a guy
that goes but i have long hair though
and she goes all right
she doesn't understand that she doesn't
know herself you have to dig deep
sweetheart know yourself and know what
attracted you to him in the first place
which was this is a guy who goes against
the norms
even though people who are five seven
should have [ __ ] absolutely short
hair right but she is attracted to a guy
that says [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and that's this guy no you can't assume
she doesn't know herself she'll know
herself she just wants him to have
shorter hair because she thinks he would
look better and she's right dude that
hair is awesome i know but like we said
it like he said he's five seven it's bad
to be five seven and have long hair you
sweep up a lot of lint yeah his hair's
dragging on the [ __ ] ground yeah dude
he's gonna [ __ ] wash it later on
there's gonna be pretzels in it and [ __ ]
[Applause]
pretzels i was that [ __ ] 7-eleven
oh man now sweetie can you hear me my
keys are too high now i'm [ __ ]
sweating yeah dude me too bro that guy
was very cool till he leaked out he was
five seven how tall is she [ __ ] 4-2
what's the thing with height what's the
thing with you in height i'm six too i'm
a tall drink of water and thank god
because if i wasn't you know how [ __ ]
ugly i'd be if i was five eight holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] but i'm not though my
friend always [ __ ] up if you were 5 8
my friend always says well by the way if
i was 5 8 i'd be a [ __ ] warlord for
real i'd be a dictator no doubt i'd be
like a napoleon thing oh dude 100
like napoleon was short as [ __ ] right
well yeah that's where the whole thing
comes i get it dude i would have they
wouldn't even call it they'd call it a
[ __ ] dalia complex from now on for
real i would be if i was short enough to
be like like what five
six if i was five six five seven i could
maybe eek out still be a comedian and be
funny five six or below five five dude
countries are getting taken over for
real i i swear to god i swear to god i'd
make a new country you could even birth
me in america like you did you might
have a whole new country in america and
we'd rise up dude you want to explain
that a little bit
like why because people would have made
fun of me and
i'm a tall drink of water and i always
had the [ __ ] gift of gab yeah sure i
agree with you but if i was short yeah
i'd also have to [ __ ] be bull i'd be
bullied right yeah growing up in my
formative years even though i was a tall
drink of water if i wasn't possibly
people say [ __ ] you and you're short
[ __ ] up i get a group rallying around
me and we take them over okay you're
saying so that would have led to you
like leading a hostile takeover of
countries eventually yeah because you
were short i would have started my cult
way earlier and it would have been on
and popping honestly okay can i say
something yeah i'm five seven yes nice
but you don't have hair so it's kind of
better dude if you had long hair we'd
have to have a word dude if you had a
long hair like that guy we'd have to
that would be
unfucking believable i mean we'd have to
have i would like him i would like him
more we'd have to have a simple word
with you dude it would be awful it would
be awful he's five seven and we love him
dude but he's he's got he's bald dude
yeah if he had long hair we'd have to
have a simple word with him we'd have to
sit him down and we'd be like dude he'd
be like you got to cut this [ __ ] man
you're five seven
and he and he might fight it but he'd
know it was better because we [ __ ]
love him and we'd [ __ ] coach him into
it remember when he was fighting getting
rid of all of it everyone does that but
that was
if you just to extend this one if you
are bald or balding and
it's just going or it's basically almost
gone you got like the ring or just a
little bit on top a little bit whatever
not that you're like trying to hide it
but like you still want to hang on to
the the vestiges of what was once a full
head of hair get rid of it get
[ __ ]
of it
it depends on what kind of [ __ ]
bald uh
if you the ring is honestly dude of it
the ring works for some guys man who's
who's it work for guys who wear tweed
jackets
who wears a tweed jacket guys with the
ring
oh that's a circular face it's like a
hand in hand dude it's like you know if
you got the ring
you got patches on your but you got
patches on your elbows the ring works
for you you know what i mean i mean i
think you're thinking of people like in
movies in 1970 if you sit on a desk with
one foot on the ground and one foot up a
little bit halfway down
the ring works for you okay
had the ring has like a little ring
sometimes that was an anomaly though he
got rid of it he's balled his [ __ ]
[ __ ] now also we know what's happening
he's great he's got a brain disease so
okay well that's unconnected
i think so yeah no i know so okay okay
head was more exposed is what i'm saying
hi matt and chris
i am a 35 year old happily married woman
i have a question for you about
friendships
um
basically my whole life
i've had
only close friendships with men i
haven't really been able to
make and sustain relationships
or friendships with women
um
i don't know why i just always felt more
comfortable around men i could be myself
around men there's like less drama i
don't know maybe i'm just stereotyping
but i
want to have friends with women and i
feel like i'm kind of lacking that in my
life and that
female perspective and stuff so
basically my question is why do you
think that is and what would you suggest
for me
and shout out to calvin because he's the
best oh
damn i was gonna [ __ ] do a joke and
that just wore me right the [ __ ] up and
i already missed the moment it's so
sweet okay well uh you gotta have female
friends i mean i know that chicks only
really are friends for two years and
then they up hating each other right
because that's what happens with all
chicks they're like oh my god look at my
wifey and then two years later you'd be
like how's amanda or whoever and they'll
be like that [ __ ] [ __ ] stole my man
[ __ ] her i ran her over and you're like
what
right but the point is
you don't want to be
that white guy in the group of only
black friends and you don't have white
friends that guy is just like you know
hey what's up man and trying to act all
like you're [ __ ] like you know like
one of the guy i could drink she doesn't
seem like one of these girls but like
one of these chicks was like i can drink
dudes under the table and it's just like
dude stop trying to prove it that way i
don't think that's what she's doing but
you gotta start having
more friends than just the one sex
because
really what's happening is
you're a woman you got to [ __ ] love
yourself more than that you're a woman
you love women
so [ __ ] be friends with women you
don't want to be that annoying guy
that's like what the [ __ ] they only hang
out with the certain people but here's
the thing here's here's where i would
if she clearly not doesn't have anything
against women what's that that's the
thing that i don't know what's happened
in her life
to up to this point is that through
whatever reason happenstance whatever
the [ __ ] she's only made good friends
who are men i would definitely
not suggest
making friends with a woman just because
she's a woman yeah that's bad
you don't want to do that that's just
stupid so i think that
just know
moving forward
that you are maybe would prefer another
female friend but don't like make it
happen that's asking for trouble that's
like when you're looking for a
relationship and you're just like need
to have a partner need to get in a
relationship you just ignore red flags
when you should be absolutely noticing
them and steering clear good point i
think you've probably just made male
friends because you've happened to make
male friends maybe she had a good
positive male figure in her life when
she was growing up right like her dad
maybe her dad was you know really a
great dad i mean maybe her mom's a great
mom i don't know but maybe you just felt
more connected to her your dad or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah or or the mailman
was really cool or something or maybe
what i said you know what i mean
maybe it's just what i said no but uh it
could be both right yeah it could be
both so so it could be both of what
people will be both said right it could
be right no that's true so um
yeah i don't know i i think that
i mean she said she wants to be friends
with women she did yeah if she had like
a yeah exactly i i you know what ask
yourself why
right yeah like why do you want to be
friends with women is life working out
or why don't you have female friends if
it really is just happenstance [ __ ] it
it's not a problem i guess like if
there's a reason then yeah look at that
but what i've come up what i've come to
learn in this past three minutes is dude
like if your life is happy
and you're chilling you got a nice cute
dog you're happily married
maybe it's just [ __ ]
maybe that's it like i know a guy i know
i know i keep bringing it back to this
but i know a white guy with a bunch of
black friends and that's kind of all
he's got he's black friends and he's
happy and everyone's like that guy only
hangs out with black guys and it's like
yeah but it's like well what the [ __ ]
he's happy yeah
and as a white guy you feel a little
[ __ ] you're like but he's even white
he doesn't want to hang out with me and
you're like maybe that has a problem
with me you know what i mean but it's
deeper but you know what i'm saying
deeper for sure yeah but like um i think
usually when this is the case it's
there's actually not a deeper thing it
certainly doesn't seem the case for this
woman
she wants female friends
i don't know i don't i don't i actually
don't
i've heard people with complaints like
this before like why do i have or i've
actually heard people be like i don't
trust that woman she only has guy
friends i don't
know what is up with that i don't know
what the implication is supposed to be
yeah
it's weird to
she seems like a totally nice person she
could be a [ __ ] crazy lunatic before
we know but she seems like a sweet
person
that doesn't fit the
type of what she's saying do you know
what i mean what is the type like
guy friends [ __ ] these [ __ ] okay well
yeah that's the problem right she should
say it like that and then we'd get it
more but um but the fact that she's
saying it the way she's saying it makes
me think there actually isn't the
problem right right right yes of course
yes but um it's also you could also go
back to what i was saying which it's
nice to not have female friends because
if you're a female with female friend
with a female friend basically what
you're doing is gifting yourself an
enemy in two years so next
you're gifting yourself an enemy in two
years okay last one mm-hmm great
what up man what's up
arch criminal i need some advice on how
to not take things so personally so the
guy sometimes people make comments or
joke um even my friends and stuff and i
can find myself like
becoming uh offended in my head and
thinking of things like well they
shouldn't have said that because i could
say this or whatever um
i just feel like it's an issue i kind of
need to work on and i feel like you boys
are the people to come to to solve this
issue so let me know some advice on how
to not take things so personal peace
okay that's a great question and i love
that he's that he's it cuts deep aware
of
of this and and thinking but here's the
thing there's like a fine line between
when it comes to taking things
personally as he's saying it there's a
fine line between people
attacking you or being shitty or being
mean or actually negging you
and just either
joking all in good fun didn't mean
anything by it
and and so
i think for the former the things that
fall under that bucket
you can take that [ __ ] personally and
and consider either not being friend to
that person not having that person
around whatever the [ __ ] but about the
things that i'm assuming he means which
are generally they didn't mean any harm
by it yeah they're just [ __ ] around
whatever it is
right yeah uh
i think that
i don't know dude i mean i'm i'm not
that
bad at this i don't take [ __ ] that
personally when i know someone's [ __ ]
around i have a uh uh somebody told me a
saying
um
it's something like other people's
opinions of me aren't my business
yeah and that's that kind of like struck
a chord with me uh because like i mean
people say awful [ __ ] about celebrities
online people say awful [ __ ] about me
online and like you know i
i i it honestly like i know i give this
um
image of this guy who like nothing
bothers me and [ __ ] but like it does
dude like it [ __ ] really bothers me
you know um
and it hurts and it [ __ ] like
i get in my head about it and [ __ ] and
like
so i want to be like shrug it off
uh
and and keep moving
um
which is good advice but also
i get when it really cuts deep you know
because sometimes the same comment made
in a and you're in a different mood
could [ __ ] you up
and
one day and not the next day you know
so
that goes back to
um
you know you're 50 of somebody saying
something to you because somebody said
something that's 50 of it and then you
taking it is another 50 right you only
own 50 of what you even say in this
world but
all you can do is here's something i do
when when that [ __ ] gets to me whether
it's comments in person that somebody
says like
um you know like i remember one one time
one guy came up to me and he was like
hey are you that guy from that show and
i said yeah
i won't say the show but he was like
he's like yeah that show [ __ ] sucks
and um
what a guy yeah it was [ __ ] awful and
i got mad you know and i realized i was
mad
because um
it hurt my [ __ ] feelings dude and i
knew
he probably didn't even watch the show
he was just being an [ __ ]
um
and back then i don't i did not have the
tools that i do now when people say
stuff like i mean that something that
really has not happened in a very long
time but it might happen again and
certainly online way worse [ __ ] happens
i mean people
[ __ ] say i'm gonna cut your [ __ ]
head off and [ __ ] it's awful but
you know
look the
the only thing that
you can do is
when to for me when something like that
happens i immediately think of the stuff
that i'm grateful for like
because that's that helps me like i
think of like i think of calvin i think
of you i think of you know my family
and the people who i have that are real
friends that support me my fiance and
[ __ ] like that and the fans man like the
people that show up to my shows and like
it just it helps it helps to
just immediately put yourself into a
different mind state and that coupled
with
what somebody else thinks of you is not
your business
um
[Music]
you know you can get yourself out of
some [ __ ] really dark
times i have so you know it seems like
you're doing okay you do look like a
[ __ ] straight-up convict yeah it's a
straight-up art criminal yeah
the long-sleeve shirt the car here the
chains well i think that one thing is
that that i've actually for some reason
i feel like i stumbled upon this and
it's something that i always keep in
mind that has actually really helped me
and it's when someone says something
shitty about you to you
they're trying to upset you
and so if someone's trying to upset you
by telling you something about you
take that for exactly what it is they're
tooling around in their head for
something
to make you mad
don't give them what they want first of
all and second of all if they're trying
to make you mad they're probably
reaching for it anyway it might not even
be [ __ ] true
they're probably just doing it to
specifically to upset you and you can't
be giving these [ __ ] what they
want second of all act like you didn't
[ __ ] hear it you'll be surprised at
how quickly you [ __ ] forget it
it doesn't [ __ ] and then
also who the [ __ ] [ __ ] cares what
[ __ ] somebody else has to say about
you i don't even care what that guy's
saying if you think it's [ __ ] true
[ __ ] fine but chances are you only
think it's true because somebody some
[ __ ] like that has said it to you
then or before [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah it's
too short we're all gonna die yeah well
not i mean not everyone has died yet but
we're all gonna die though not sure
there's still people alive
no they're gonna die
jesus christ don't make that face okay
um you could also if somebody says
something [ __ ] about you you can just be
like nah ah that's you
well you could do that and then do it
spin move and then [ __ ]
um
yeah so that's i don't know man i feel
you though dude the way he was talking
about it made me feel for him like i
feel bad you know and i don't know why
he's in a [ __ ] makeup trailer but he
was and
um and it's fine uh and get a different
hair style now no way dude the hair was
killed it was this [ __ ] but what are we
in the [ __ ] 80s dude yeah [ __ ]
extra in red dawn no you're not he's
owning the arch criminal book he is real
true that's true and now that it's 2022
you can kind of get away with whatever
but he is white so he might want to
[ __ ] change it up a little bit he
looks like an arch criminal a smooth
criminal
we like him don't take it personally
life's too short we're all going to
[ __ ] die and you know what the person
that said it to you that is probably
that has said something that it's gonna
that you took offense to you took too
personally it's probably gonna die a
miserable [ __ ] death yeah so don't
sweat him and he might even die first
you can do that if somebody says
something shitty to you you'd be like
man you probably died before me
moving [ __ ] or moon walk out dude all
right ill that would be especially with
that hair we're gonna have that's
actually true but we're gonna have an
intervention with you about the spin
move thing because i don't know what's
going on with you but it's all you think
about and it's becoming a real problem
it's getting in the way of our show of
the advice you give okay and pretty soon
it's gonna start leaking into your
actual life you're gonna start doing
spin moves on people i mean i've done
them you've done a spin move
in like a football game
i did it once when a guy uh i held the
door open for a guy and then he didn't
say thank you and what'd you do i did a
spin move and i said held it open for
you no yeah i did really you're my hero
then
i mean that's [ __ ] pissed me off yeah
well how did you feel after you did it
though uh it was so
much like free emotion and like it was
everything it was freeing it was rage it
was happiness i mean it was uh unreal so
we've stumbled upon something one time a
spin move is a good idea next time
somebody says something that you take
personal offense to snap turn your legs
do a [ __ ] spin move and say
well i said held it open for you what
should he say oh him uh you're gonna die
sooner than me yeah
spin move you probably died before me
yeah
[Laughter]
i mean that would you'd instantly win
that interaction dude i just you leave
thinking about that not what the
[ __ ] said to piss you off yeah
right right right
yeah true yeah that's yeah i literally
think i think that holding a door open
for somebody if somebody doesn't say
thank you or something it's the rudest
thing and it's also harder to not say
something to somebody
than to just be like that because you're
fighting the urge yeah it's like i'm
looking at you opening the door you're
fighting the urge you look at me and you
fight the urge to say something isn't it
crazy and then you just say nah and you
don't do it you don't say [ __ ] you walk
out isn't it crazy isn't it crazy
there's this neighbor that since i've
moved i have i've had this like
kind of growing
uh
hatred for gone and i try not to hate
him but i just you know what i just do
he listens and i hope he does
and
i walk
when i walk my dog i see him and like
i'm a paul simon song i'm always like
weighing whether i should [ __ ] say
say hi or whatever because he's such a
dick he probably won't say hi back to me
but he's like a car guy and he's like
working on a car in his garage oh wow
and i happened to walk by when he was
working on it and i actually said
we actually locked eyes and said hey to
each other so i know he saw me yeah and
i were walking by and i said oh man this
one's cool i can't wait to see this one
he didn't
say
anything
yeah yeah that's
that's really odd that's so odd like how
yeah i would do so many [ __ ] spin
moves yeah you would have just been
spinning down the street dude
caught up with your legs
dude i just don't understand when
somebody you you should have stopped and
said i said i can't wait to see this one
when it's done no i said you know what i
actually said i said oh
just like that i was walking the whole
time but i said it nice that's pretty
much a spin move dude i don't understand
that [ __ ] i don't understand that it's
really weird man it's like don't be
actively rude for no reason yeah you're
trying to make the world worse when you
do that you're trying
trying
not just doing it but trying actively
trying to make the world a worse place
interesting you're trying to make the
world a worse more miserable place than
it already is and let me tell you
something it's bad and miserable as it
is wow yeah it's a dark yeah and then on
such a dark note but also do you think
that they know they're doing that
they're trying to i think it's their
past i got all caught up to first of all
who is this guy that lives next to you
he's like a [ __ ] what's that guy in
uh the chris uh who's that actor uh he
really feels there's a lot of them so
you gotta narrow it down [ __ ] the
older one cooper chris cooper is like a
chris cooper character yeah he's like
chris cooper and american beauty right
okay
guys that's what i'm thinking of called
me out but i mean many characters like
that but okay sure uh but yeah his his
wife's weird too yeah of course she is
when she walks her dogs all of which are
[ __ ] mean as hell my dog of course
they are my dog's just trotted by all
quiet which she never really is but she
is around these dogs because they're all
like
going forward so they talked more than
the people then yeah but then she talks
to her dogs and i can hear her talking
to her dog all the way down she's like
we don't do that you know be nicer be
nicer
and i'm like is she doing this for me
yeah like does she think she's going to
do it also talk to your husband say that
she wears three masks
outside cough in her face out [ __ ]
side off in her face
on a quiet street where there's nobody
that's yeah that's unbelievable does the
guy do it no well then she's going to
get it anyway
if she's going to get it if he sees his
mouth he's in his [ __ ] house with his
mouth open and she's [ __ ] gonna get
it she's not in her house with three
masks on this is insane dude you can't
get covered outside when you're walking
alone there's wind i talk about this in
my act but like dude come see me phoenix
april 30th but it's like chrisley.com
but it's like so annoying that [ __ ]
people do this they got their priorities
are so mixed up
she's walking her dog trying to correct
her dog barking wearing three masks and
letting her husband be piece of [ __ ]
yeah dude all of these things are
backwards get your priority get your
priorities activated talk to your
husband stop trying to correct your dogs
from barking and take off at least
absolutely dude it's so
[ __ ] whack people are crazy he also
ha uh he's also not only a car guy but
he's like one of those older guys who
like
riffs at night sometimes on his guitar
he's got an amp and everything this
guy's the most in the world listen to
this though it gets way worse than that
for three hours one night late from like
ten to one or maybe like nine to
midnight
i i it's just gonna sound not true but i
promise you it's 100 true without any
kind of any added [ __ ] he sprouts
with he just did this he just did the
part of the bon jovi song that goes like
this
dead or alive and he did the guitar part
and that and saying that and that's it
and he sings it yeah and he sings it in
just that part though dude this podcast
should have only been about that moment
you i can't believe you're bringing it
out now we'll do a whole episode about
it he goes wow now
what's the guitar part of it i don't
know you don't even know when you heard
it so much no we can't play it so um
because of the [ __ ] amount of
decision but [ __ ] wounded is he good
at it at least
[ __ ] no
not even a little bit but neither is bon
jovi
no actually nothing could be
less
nothing could be more annoying to be
honest yeah because if you think about
it like think of something more annoying
like what's more annoying he [ __ ]
comes up to your driveway knocks on your
door you open it up and his [ __ ] out
and he goes my [ __ ] and then [ __ ]
walking wait that's another one amazing
because you'll be like what the [ __ ] i
would love that you can't think of
anything more annoying
no no no no maybe if you [ __ ]
you know what i mean maybe doing that
for [ __ ] 35 minutes at a time but but
he was doing that for three hours three
hours and not talking to you when you do
that i know isn't that [ __ ] wild
let's go beat this guy up right now okay
let's go let's go we should we wrap up
the episode uh we should wrap up the
episode uh somebody's getting about to
get handled after this episode dude
so you guys thanks april 30th i'll be in
uh phoenix crystalia.com and uh this was
a great episode uh if i don't say so
myself if i do say to myself uh give
your advice to the people in the
comments and we'll reply to the [ __ ]
best ones uh below here uh subscribe to
the channel and uh make friends in the
comments and also uh these were good
ones these [ __ ] weeks ask a question
yeah also ask a question
uh and go to what is the thing no the
links below the links below links below
you can go go to the link and then send
in a video
and uh we like the juicy ones these are
[ __ ] these were good ones today for
real they were good yeah but that's
because we're getting good ones now
because the you know the show's getting
bigger people are getting it the show's
getting bigger and bigger it's remaining
at the top of the charts yeah it is and
honestly it just keeps on doubling until
they kill us and um so i think that uh
ask a question and that's it right you
think that asks a question and that's it
yeah ask a [ __ ] question get a great
[ __ ] answer we're ready for more
we'll see you next week lifeline
[Music]